el cob y 19 llegó al palacio del elíseo
con el positivo del presidente francés
emmanuel macrón según presidencia es muy
probable que macro se contagiase durante
el consejo europeo la semana pasada
nadie ni siquiera el presidente de la
república está a salvo de esto que pagan
u2 es ahora el líder del ejecutivo
francés se encuentra en aislamiento
junto a su esposa brigitte quien dio
negativo y ha cancelado todos los
próximos viajes oficiales que son en
cuanto al presidente de la república es
un ejemplo para todos los franceses se
aisló al menor síntoma esto es
exactamente lo que decimos a todos los
franceses de jose tras la confirmación
del positivo por kobe 19 de macrón se
llevó a cabo un estricto rastreo
numerosos jefes de estado y funcionarios
se realizaron la prueba entre ellos el
presidente del gobierno español pedro
sánchez el mandatario portugués antonio
costa o el primer ministro francés yann
castex todos ellos negativos pese a esto
varios de los políticos y funcionarios
que mantuvieron estrecho contacto con
macrón en los últimos días entrarán en
cuarentena durante una semana el lunes
durante una conferencia en parís macrón
de un polémico apretón de manos al jefe
de la ocde
mexicano josé ángel gurría el jefe de
estado fue uno de los primeros en
adoptar los saludos a distancia y rara
vez fue visto sin mascarilla pero según
los críticos mostraba signos de haber
bajado la guardia